[Music]
are those your shoes those are my shoes
I made them to the one they're the ones
I'm wearing now
you handmade though I haven't made these
yeah I even put the Nike logo on the
back they gave me some on running shoes
that's what I'm wearing yeah dude the
collabs they offered me those they
offered me I was like [ __ ] yeah that's
the difference between us
I was they're like it's like Roger
Federer's brand and they gave me them
for free I was like [ __ ] yeah you got to
keep them yeah
10.
what give me him give me him I'm not
giving them to you
I'm keeping giving them sick you're
never gonna wear them give them a ride
give them to Ryan give them to me I'm
gonna let them sit in my closet yeah
and collect dust so we get invited to
this sorry
event
and uh
you know we're dripped the [ __ ] out but
in order for us to get these outfits we
had to go meet with some of their you
know
some people from the brand
to style us my outfit on that day it
stood out here
and it stood out most places I go
because I don't typically wear a
monochrome white or like colors like
that then I go to the Edition hotel and
I hop out
and I give my keys to the valet
and I notice immediately hey
nice color palette my guy
hope the rest of the employees don't
look like this and then I go into the
hotel and I'm like [ __ ] me I look like I
work here
hmm
and I know this because the employees
keep looking at me and they keep double
taking
but they're not double taking like they
know me they're double taking like did
that guy start
did he start here today who is that yeah
I'm like I'm thankfully the pants had
like loops and cargo pants on them so
that was kind of giving it away
but so then I guess if the hotel are
throwing you their keys yeah borderline
so I go up to the check-in desk and I'm
waiting to speak with someone
and the employees keep looking at me and
then looking back down at their
computers and I'm like
I don't want to have to [ __ ] tell
them I don't work here so I just kind of
stand my own I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
wait here until someone says some [ __ ]
to me there's a guy behind me
and then one of the employees looks
around me and goes I'll take you right
here sir and you're like I'm like the
[ __ ]
so this guy walks ahead of me and I and
it's a very
clear thing none of the guests were
wearing white they're all wearing dark
colors they're all wearing black and
blue it was it was such an obvious
contrast it I'm like of course this
would happen so then this guy goes
around me and I'm like the [ __ ]
who's this dude
and then he checks in and then he turns
around starts heading to the elevator he
walks in front of me and I'm like oh
it's Sean Evans
it was like a weird thing where I'm like
I think I'm gonna end up in the elevator
in a second so I'll just say what's up
to him then so I walk up to the guy I'm
like hey I'm here for I gotta get to the
Sweet number they say I'll just take the
elevator off I'm like cool hop in the
elevator I walk up to Sean I'm like
Shawn he looks at me kind of bewildered
I'm like Noel and it's like tiny that's
all I say is Tiny and he goes oh my
he's like dude I thought that was you
oh I was like you this guy kind of looks
like he works here so I didn't say
anything
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so then we get to the floor I have to
get off and I step off the floor and
he's like what are you doing here I'm
like I'm here for a fashion in the
elevator
shots on me
I just clocked in that's what I should
have said yeah
I just clocked in so that's what I get
for trying to wear a [ __ ] vest right
before the doors close his keys come
flying out yeah it's doing that have it
ready for me
it was funny when I went up and they
handed me the varsity jacket
they're like we can put in a bag I'm
like I'll wear it down
[Laughter]
because it fit that's good it looked
good with the outfit I'm like I'm
wearing this [ __ ] down
and I wore it out and it was a party was
fun it was fun we saw Dojo yeah shout
out Dojo partying with her till like two
yeah me and Alina were falling asleep
I I found that one couch upstairs I'm
like I'm not [ __ ] leaving yeah yeah I
just planted yeah
yeah I mean it parties like that it's
like fashion parties are so different
than the normal typical La [ __ ] I also I
feel like you see a lot of influencers
when you're out and stuff like that but
yeah fashion parties is like entirely
different and everyone looks way cooler
because everyone's wearing like
experimental [ __ ] yeah and it's just
like people from
Paris yeah really experimental [ __ ] like
uh varsity jackets yeah exactly no I
meant like the people that actually work
in fashion yeah yeah no definitely there
were some insane fits that night
seriously
and I I was telling Elena like
you know who all the models are yeah
they just have crazy ass looks you know
who I [ __ ] sat beside we're sitting
in this booth like the corner one by the
bar and there's two guys just sitting
there I already know what you're gonna
say we're good and what did I tell you
no no I just know he like there wasn't
that many people yeah there wasn't that
many people there and he they're like oh
we're gonna go for a smoke or something
like that and I had just like introduced
myself because we had sat at that table
first laughed and we came back and was
like hey fellas like we're back blah
blah met the two guys and the guy's like
oh I'm James and then the other guy said
his name and then they like left to go
smoke a cigarette and he left his camera
or something I was like holding it and
he came back and he was like oh that's
mine and I'm like oh [ __ ] sorry man and
I give it back to him and as he's
leaving I'm like wait that was [ __ ]
James Blake
because he was like yeah you didn't know
that I was like no I would well who did
you think I was gonna say I'll tell you
in a second but that's hilarious [ __ ]
crazy I I just noticed uh Denzel Curry
and Thundercat yeah yeah that's all I'm
walking too yeah it was pretty cool
yeah I didn't realize Denzel had grown
his hair back out so I was like oh
oh
it was just one of those took me a
second
celebrities celebs dude
[ __ ]
brushing shoulders well hey hey shout
out those are she uh you know that was a
that was a pretty surreal thing
she was like walking up the stairs
and as she's walking upstairs I just you
know her security guards in front of her
and I just kind of like look and she
looks at me and her face is very like
kind of friendly gesture towards me or
expression and I'm like hey
and she clears her security guard she's
like oh my God Noel hi you're so funny
and walked away and I was like
had you never met her before I've not
met her before yeah so I was like that
that was cool yeah
priest she's cool man love your Muse a
girl loves your Muse too love your Muse
yeah
I love your Muse you're my muse sorry
muse no you're not your music is my muse
that was cool
um
ball Bros it's all bros sorry what I
said baldies yo we're both bald
oh you know who's there who
[ __ ] the hotel manager from the first
season of White Lotus no way yeah dude
no way yeah well pull up that boy that's
sick I was the most geeked about him I
don't I didn't want to say [ __ ] though
Murray Bartlett dude that's wild that
man was there he was chilling and he
seemed like a really nice guy